the Joe Rogan experience hey I went to
this nightclub in Germany in Berlin it
was [ __ ] so [ __ ] dude I've been
having fog going around places yeah yeah
yeah what was it okay
it's [ __ ] bats they do [ __ ] on
another level there I'm not any EDM and
stuff but like it was great as soon as
you walk in it's like okay first of all
you can't even get in oh my god okay
the first thing you see when you get in
is just a bunch of people in leather
worn out it goes from Friday night
midnight and so like Monday about noon
well you need to stay in and do hella
drugs and just dance for like techno and
like house music on different floors
will die in there they must they must
they must go too hard and have heart
attacks yeah but everyone yeah they must
yeah but when you're down there it's on
the third level where there's no and
just people just coming down I went in
like a day and a half so it was like
Sunday when I went so people are just
like out of it sweaty girls with like
tutus and like whatever there's a
coat-check place where somebody said
somebody check their [ __ ] one time well
yeah yeah like you can take it for me
yeah okay the very first thing I saw I
go in it's overwhelming me and my
promoter were there we're like this is
[ __ ] too much and we're like all
right let's get beers and I saw this is
a great dude the way to get is to wear
all black or wear leather or just be
with gay people gay people just get in
and they make sure it's like a good time
for everybody and uh they make you put a
sticker over your phone no pictures
they'll throw you the [ __ ] out
do whatever drugs you want anyway as
soon as I see it there's a guy at the
end of the bar just getting jerked off
as he's ordering by a guy or a girl by a
guy from the top by a guy yeah yeah and
he's [ __ ] the beer out of it on drugs
I still try to get some dudes other hand
is just gone inside his [ __ ] yeah a
full like cuz it didn't make sense the
joyce's yeah I think I mean I don't know
something it might have an opers it
might have been I don't know what was
doing at the inside it might have been
open or closed like a pop it yeah and
then it's just debauchery
you just get drugs in the bathroom
and dance and dance and dance oh yeah
full you see full like [ __ ] going on
Wow
it's like anything goes people are out
with 30 like dicks dicks out just
[ __ ] jumping and dancing we gave
everybody drugs that's what they would
do
oh my gosh yeah good times it was the
best you just walk around and you go to
the bathroom somebody read she was
looking for like anything we'll be
trying to get ecstasy probably right
Molly you know something like that
somebody eventually gave me one I was
like I got enough for my promoter got to
and he was like no no I'm going home I'm
only staying till like 3:00 I got my
kids like soccer game tomorrow and I was
like alright so I'll throw this out
there
Oh we'll just throw out the exercises
are [ __ ] relax so he took something
that we just start dancing man it was so
fun the music is nuts it they got like
the best DJs in the world like go down
there and just let me show off no just
like do sets yeah it's kind of like the
Comedy Store kinda like the Comedy Store
it's like the best comics in the world
doing what 15 bucks nothing to do with
the money they're trying to show off Wow
Wow
God it was so [ __ ] fun they just have
this like nightclub culture they'll even
have like rockabilly bars there and then
people are dancing on the back do you
remember when the early days the
internet you would get [ __ ] porn from
Germany uh-huh it was always from
Germany they go they go whatever you're
enter just go for it why Germany like do
you think after World War two they just
went crazy no I think that after World
War two I think after the Berlin Wall
fell I think it's all reaction to that
[ __ ] really yeah because they're not
really in Berlin at least they're not
really thinking about the Holocaust
anymore they're thinking about that
east-west that's their most recent
massive restorable
you know and that was yeah yeah that was
during the Reagan administration wasn't
mr. Bob McAuliffe tear down that wall
didn't I know I think I know somebody
who had a piece of the wall I had one
you could buy it at Spencer's and stuff
yeah yeah a PC could also buy a poster
of a guy with this like that Oh dick
Ruthven just like a little bit you know
it's like hanging out with a cowboy hat
mmm
[Applause]